الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا زاد الاحوال سوءا
فالوضع كان متهلكا اساسا بسبب الحرب
المتواصله في البلاد منذ اكثر من عشر
سنوات البنيه التحتيه وشبكات المياه
والكهرباء والصرف الصحي باتت مدمره بشكل
كامل وهو ما ينذر بوضع صحي صعب للغايه
بهذا الخصوصا فدت منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيوسف ان من بين الاولويات
الفوريه هي توفير امكانيه الحصول على مياه
صالحه للشرب وخدمات صرف صحي لمنع انتشار
الامراض على غرار الكوليرا التي تسجل
انتشارا منذ اشهر في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
الناس كانوا بالفعل الغارقين في الازمه
وبالطبع الزلزال يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه
الوضع الصحي تحت الضغط ايضا نقص الوقود
والتضخم والازمه الاقتصاديه وتاثر النظام
الصحي بشده جراء وباء كوفيد 19 كلها اشياء
تجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه
اذا مشاهدينا هذا الان خبر عاجل اعلام
اللبنانيه تحدث عن هزه ارضيه شعره بها
سكان عدد من المناطق في البلاد قبل ذلك
دمشق كانت كذلك اعلنت عن تسجيل هزه ارضيه
بعد قليل سنتابع مع مراسلنا من سوريا بعد
قليل اذا اما على صعيد الوضع الانساني
الزلزال رش الملحه على جروح السوريين
الذين عاقبتهم السياسه والطبيعه بل حتى
الجغرافيا كانت قاسيه على من ذهبوا الى
الجنوب الشمالي لتركيا فعاشوا ويلات
الزلزال ليعود بعضهم ادراجه اما ميتا او
منكوبا فمئنه السوريين الذين يقطنون
الاراضي التركيه وتضرروا من الزلزال
المدمر بداوا في العبور الى الاراضي
السوريه وذلك بحثا عن مكان للمبيت او دعما
لاهاليهم بعد الفاتحه
المعابر الحدوديه التي فتحت كانت شهده
ايضا على عوده بطعم الموت للمئات من
السوريين فقد دخلت العديد من الشاحنات
الاراضي السوريه محمله بجثامين من قضوا في
الزلزال في تركيا العديد من العائلات
السوريه فضلت نقل جثث ذويها الى الداخل
السوري وخاصه ممن تعود اصولهم الى ادلب
وريف حلب او ممن لهم اقارب في باقي
المحافظات السوريه